this korean guy sends us a [ __ ] email
saying like yo it's super disrespectful
that you guys have this [ __ ] name
this gopher bro thing it belongs to you
know the gopher boat foundation the
military people and i was like
you're korean dude
this is a japanese thing we have a
japanese owner yeah and this fool didn't
even [ __ ] know yeah that we were
working with the gopher bro foundation
yeah because he didn't care to ask yeah
he just sent us a [ __ ] scathing email
yeah and i just remember i wrote back a
super disrespectful [ __ ] and i sent him
all these links i was like that's
[ __ ] funny did you even look in five
four
three two one
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the game i didn't see you
there yeah that's a classic yeah that's
a classic movie i had a um there's a
well you guys don't know you should know
him he's a youtuber friend of mine who
um
back in the day he used to start his uh
videos
with his chair turned around and he had
a mug or something he was like
oh [ __ ] guys i didn't see you guys there
and then i remember during thanksgiving
yeah uh i started roasting this fool i
was like yo how the [ __ ] do you not know
they're there when you're the one who
turned the camera you [ __ ] dummy
all right and you know everybody's like
roasting them and [ __ ] yeah yeah
lo and behold i found out that he was so
hurt by that [ __ ]
i was like cute you just have a history
of hurting people
roasting him that's why you got that gun
pointed at your dick bro but it's not
like i don't get roasted too like
everybody gets roasted you know what it
means no but it's a different kind of
roasting you know look some people are
just better at roasting than others and
uh
you know when uh
you're the type of person who's better
at roasting
some people can really be hurt by it man
you know what the thing is too is like i
just remember as a kid like one of the
things that never really worked out was
when people would roast each other
there's like a certain level of a line
you don't cross right i always cross
that line because i'm always trying to
win yeah you know so it would be like
some [ __ ] where somebody would make a
fat joke or something like that right
and i was and i would just go something
i know something about them that they
don't like
and i would just be like
i'm gonna do that
yeah well how about your stupid dead dad
for dying
it's like oh man come on
like uh one time
this dude got hella mad at me which it
was understandable but his problem was
that like i said one of the biggest
things that i don't like is people who
dish it but can't take it yeah like if
you don't want any of the heat to stay
out the [ __ ] kitchen you know because
you can't just free will just
clown on people and then not get clap
back at oh man you you talking about
that sorry it has changed real quick
we'll come back but it may made me uh
remember what i was thinking about
recently which was
there's a lot of people who like to say
oh i like people who are open-minded
but you quickly realize you're not
open-minded and open-minded at all the
[ __ ] is you talking about that's all
twitter dude yeah and i'm like dude it's
a [ __ ] two-way street man
you have to open your mind to be
accepting of things and as a result then
you can coexist with these other
open-minded people and talk about things
very openly but
that's like the have you ever seen that
girl in the group that says [ __ ] like
this i'm really mature for my age
are the most immature person i've ever
met in my [ __ ] life these cliche
statements i i'm i'm a very old you know
why person you know why yes i mentioned
that it's a girl and the only reason why
that girl thinks like that yeah is it
because a bunch of perverted older oppas
that wants to [ __ ] you so they always
tell you exactly that you're super
mature it's like nothing because they
want to [ __ ] you you're not mature if
you have to verbally tell people that
you are more mature for your age than
you actually are yeah most likely you're
[ __ ] not yeah and usually the way
they say you know people always say that
i'm like more mature for my age you know
you got duped because you're around i
was like is it also a coincidence that
all your friends are a bunch of guys
yeah what's your dm's look like yeah
show me your [ __ ] dms [ __ ]
you know the people you're getting them
from but it's it's the exact same [ __ ]
bro you know like what you just said
they they they they can dish it but they
can't take it i hate that [ __ ] man it's
just so obnoxious like yeah but i i do
understand too
there has to be like a certain level of
like don't cross that line i just i just
see that line one line i gotta i gotta
get to the finish
i remember this fool got mad at me
because
he
i mean i think he's like half joking but
he's like half of reals but he was like
making fat jokes at me right whatever
what now which is the go-to thing when
you're a fat person right and then i
literally looked at him and then
one of the things that we all knew
within our group but nobody really said
it was that his girlfriend looked
exactly like his mom like
and so right oh man and i got comments
too when people say you know mario looks
like your mom and i looked at merrill's
like no not really there's like one
specific picture where she kind of looks
like my mom uh-huh but she looks nothing
like i don't think yeah i think they'd
look a lot absolutely yeah and so i
remember i uh i looked at him i was like
so how do you like [ __ ] your mom
every night
but nobody ever said that to him but
everybody knew that joke okay so
everybody started busting up laughing
right i was like how's your mom's [ __ ]
feel every night dude and i just kept
going in on this dude right
and then so his girlfriend we were at
dinner and his girlfriend comes in and
everybody goes oh
[ __ ] his mom's here right
and i was like oh mrs kim please have a
seat and she's like i don't get it why
are you guys laughing this fool's
getting super [ __ ] mad he's like too
far bro i was like dog we're having
[ __ ] dinner and you just start
busting fat jokes on me out of nowhere i
didn't say [ __ ] to you yeah there's no
you've already went there yeah you can't
do that [ __ ] because it's always easy to
pick on the person that has something
very easy to make fun of but it's like
you do know i've been friends with you
for [ __ ] like six years yeah i know
everything about you i know everything
that makes you insecure i know every i'm
going to [ __ ] murder you yeah so like
we just kept making fun of him that he's
like [ __ ] his mom and then later on
he's like you know i [ __ ] broke up
with her because i couldn't get the fact
that you know she looks like my mom
come on guys like that's not the reason
you guys just didn't work out right also
yeah pussy's probably really nice bro
it's like come on man how do you not see
the resemblance you know what i mean
like how do you not see that
she looked
exactly like his mom dude you gotta be
a certain type of [ __ ] oblivious to
not see that and be like
there's something here that's oddly
strange i don't i can't quite put my
finger on it
oh that's what it is it's my mother
it's my mother
one of the homies when we're at that
dinner this fool cracked me the [ __ ] i
think it's so it's such a stupid joke
but he's like
so like when you guys [ __ ]
he's like so when you guys [ __ ] and then
you're spanking or is it like you're
getting back in your mouth for beating
your ass
it's like revenge sex yeah
oh man we were crying laughing dude
and this pool was like do you do you say
like who's your daddy like in korean or
english do you go up
like what do you say
i think their jokes were way worse than
mine but i think because i was the
onslaught of it i just did that one
thing that got him and everybody started
clowning floodgates man yeah you opened
the floodgates but when we look back at
that too they always thought that he
came out of nowhere with that [ __ ] like
we're just eating yeah right it's like
yeah it's it's uncalled for you know
what i mean but but again like if you do
something like that you got to be
prepared you can't roast people
not being prepared to [ __ ] have it be
dished back at you yeah you know what i
mean and if you can't laugh at yourself
and take a joke
shut the [ __ ] up yeah cause dude i have
friends now and you know people see it
like me and geo we make fun of each
other all the time
but we both
give and take right and like when she
makes fun of me it makes me [ __ ]
laugh super hard i make fun of her she
cracks the [ __ ] up too we have that
because she can dish it and she can also
take it yeah
but i just never liked those people who
couldn't do it i know especially because
they were the first ones to attack
unless all the time unless they're a
gangster with a gun
this is different
that is different my joke was so mild
dude it wasn't even anything
it was just like
hey i was like guess that joke didn't
hit you know it was like some [ __ ] like
that i don't remember the exact joke but
in the previous podcast you heard this
thing but
i basically was like hey that joke
didn't hit and he thought oh this full
thing she's so funny let me put a gun to
his dick
you funny you funny now [ __ ]
one of the worst experiences of my
[ __ ] life dude and i deleted it for a
reason
it's so funny it's just like it was gone
and then it just came back up you're
like oh what's up having these emotions
these film emotions right now i was like
that's right i remember i cried on the
phone
i think that's the funniest part you
help me close the chat hey hey you you
all right bro i was like
i'm not bad i'm not
guys like hey man this whole time kill
me man like the [ __ ] man what the [ __ ]
bro oh man i was like i wasn't gonna
kill you bro
like you good man maybe just shoot you
but not kill you bro
put a gun on me man i was like oh my god
dude as a as a
a teenager who's not used to that type
of [ __ ] that's terrifying 14 years old
too
terrifying bro yeah you bet your voice
barely changed
your puberty went backwards
but if you guys don't know um
uh one of the things that we started
this year i mean you guys always hear
this podcast we talk about uh uh secret
society right yeah so this is a how long
have we been doing super society now
four years
damn man it's been four years yeah yeah
this is the fourth year you know so now
we're on
well we crossed over the fourth year we
start we launched uh in 2017 august of
2017 so now we're into our fifth year
actually so it's it's crazy man i look
back at it and i'm like oh my goodness
where did the [ __ ] time well we lost
two years pretty much so technically
it's been about you know
two years yeah two and change yeah yeah
two years and change yeah i mean it kind
of sucks too because i think the
pandemic kind of [ __ ] a lot of us over
right yeah in a way that we didn't
really expect
uh especially when it came to closing
production right so if anybody any if
anybody you out there like anybody of
you out there if anybody out there
wants to do clothing i
don't do it
no that's so funny because that's what i
always tell like when i hear people oh
yeah you know i want to start my own
clothing line nah you don't want to do
that
you want to enjoy life right you want to
you want to actually have some fun right
don't do it then it's hard right um i i
think like the growing pains of having a
clothing company is very difficult right
so originally
my first go at it was with this with the
company gopher bro
and there was a lot of success with it
you know at the time
i knew nothing about clothing and even
now i don't really know much but i just
wanted to create a brand that uh it was
like
the opposite of like the cool kids right
so all the cool kids would have these
brands and they would wear [ __ ] only
because people would tell them it was
cool but they didn't know what the [ __ ]
it was about well you know that that
saying go for broke was is something
that resonated with me forever it's how
i live my life yeah i said well why
don't we just kind of like try to
develop something where people can
uh wear a brand that they really [ __ ]
with they understand the meaning of it
um at the time when i did it it started
with me and paul yeah paul left
um he uh he gave me the rest of the
company yeah and then with that company
um we i had uh i started up with bart
and joe yeah
they reinvested
they wanted uh equal share i was like
cool
and then we grew it to something really
really [ __ ] big yeah um at the time
we couldn't do anything with it because
it was too much and we didn't know
anything about clothing mark just
started barbell brigade um
you know just kidding news just started
popping off i wanted to do uh film and
acting and everything else yeah so we
just we're like how the [ __ ] so much we
have like not even a part-timer like it
was like a quarter of a quarter timer
three people trying to run this company
right and we couldn't run any of it and
so we had to hire out every single job
and left zero [ __ ] dollars yeah and
you know when we did make profit
everything else that we did we ended up
donating the the company the name and
whatever to the actual gopher broke
foundation right in tokyo right yeah i
found out they didn't even have
uh like legal ownership rights to
anything and so we actually decided to
just donate and work with them funny
story about that too there's a guy who
uh he owns a very popular dessert shop
out in uh
out in l.a yeah
and uh he's funny he's a korean dude
yeah but he's in like the little tokyo
area and this [ __ ] dude
starts he knows he we know one of like
the og like japanese dudes and he took
over gopher broke for us and we were
talking to him and working with him and
we're like yo how can we give back to
the gopher broke foundation and we were
working with them and everything else
and
this korean guy sends us a [ __ ] email
saying like yo it's super disrespectful
that you guys have this [ __ ] name
this gopher bro thing it belongs to you
know the gopher bro foundation the
military people and i was like
you're korean dude
this is a japanese thing we have a
japanese owner yeah and this folk didn't
even [ __ ] know yeah that we were
working with the gopher bro foundation
yeah because he didn't care to ask yeah
he just sent us a [ __ ] scathing email
yeah and i just remember i wrote back a
super disrespectful [ __ ] and i sent him
all these links i was like that's
[ __ ] funny did you even look at all
the [ __ ] of us working with gopher bro
working with the foundation the founders
and the leaders and everybody and this
will come as oh i pause like [ __ ] you
bro i was like if i see you it's on site
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
when you see this when you see this
[ __ ] korean people dude green people
on their stupid [ __ ] k rage and i was
like talking to my boy about he's like
yo who's what's your guy he goes hey i'm
sorry man like i don't know why he even
came at you like that he'd even talk to
you i was like exactly you didn't even
[ __ ] ask exactly just i mean if you
want to [ __ ] attack somebody at least
make sure you got the facts right you
know what i mean he could have simply
says like hey bro like i'm apart it's
like hey did you are you guys did you
guys get to go for a blessing because a
lot of people are talking yeah so he
heard from some a few older japanese
people that they were upset about it but
a majority were okay with it because
they knew we were working with the
gopher broke foundation it's like the
[ __ ] are you talking about guy you don't
know [ __ ] yeah
we donated everything to them we had to
buy the name gopherbroke.com from
somebody for like 10 g's we donated that
whole thing to them yeah we gave them
all of our clothing all the money
everything to them he didn't know this
[ __ ] and we were in transition of doing
it because we couldn't handle it right
and then we get this one [ __ ] email
about him like oh saying how dare we do
all this other [ __ ] i was like you're
not even japanese bro shut the [ __ ] up
you don't know [ __ ] yeah who appointed
you [ __ ] captain correct oh break
your [ __ ] kneecap because i think i
still get [ __ ] mad about that [ __ ]
it's the most korean thing he could have
ever it's just so random yeah i don't
even know you yeah it's completely
unnecessary but if again if you do want
to like come at a point of [ __ ]
attacking somebody you can ask first
make sure make sure you got the facts
right and if you still feel a certain
way about it then go into attack mode
but this podcast is brought to you by
ship station the holidays are the most
wonderful time of the year but if you're
running an online store you know that
they can get a little crazy with ship
station the hassle of shipping holiday
orders just goes away and it leaves you
happier and gives you time to run your
business i use shipstation and what i
love about it is that it's easy to use i
save money and when it comes to shipping
and the most important thing is just a
service level in general that i can give
people from it reflects well on me and
my business so if you sell anything
online i don't need to tell you that
shipping can be annoying and frustrating
and there are so many carriers and a ton
of factors that go out and figuring out
the best rate for each order well guess
what shipstation makes it easy it
doesn't matter what you have amazon
sales ebay etsy or your own website
shipstation has your back make this
holiday season a little brighter with
shipstation use my offer code
geniusbrain to get a 60 day free trial
just enough time to handle the holiday
rush just go to shipstation.com click on
the microphone at the top and enter code
genius brain shift station make ship
happen you know don't come right off the
bat with that [ __ ]
words man that was [ __ ] hilarious too
because i remember joe saw the email
that i wrote back to you and joe's like
i like to apologize for my boyfriend
because i kind of went in yeah you know
i'm like
dog and in my mind i'm like i'm gonna
[ __ ] this fool up and they were looking
at me and they're like oh you're gonna
beat his ass i was like i'm gonna beat
this full [ __ ] ass man i'm gonna
choke him and slap you
[ __ ] old [ __ ] i would beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of you dude you're in a
[ __ ] listen i'm not a gangster you're
definitely not a gangster bro
like did you ever have a [ __ ] gun
next to your dick did you crack that
joke next to somebody
[ __ ]
my life dog you got credentials bro
the [ __ ] do you know it was the most
disrespectful [ __ ] dude
but from that anyways from that like we
decided to start up a secret society
yeah
mainly him and then i i came in as an
investor um one of the hardest things
when it comes to like doing clothing too
and we were just talking about it i'm
not going to call out any clothing
companies names or something but
you know out of support you know these
are brands that i really
like and i like the people behind it in
their model and i [ __ ] with it so i
order the clothes i get the stuff it's
like damn this [ __ ] is a [ __ ] triple
a t-shirt yeah it is and if you guys
don't know what triple a t-shirts are or
gildan t-shirts by the way uh back in
the day if you guys used to go to swap
meets or if you go to swap meets now
you'll see
typically it's like korean or chinese
people yeah they have these stacks of
just blank tees and so back in the day
we used to just wear long white tees
yeah
uh long just blanks
which is nothing on in shaped heads
and they were always triple a shirts
yeah and triple a shirts are cheap as
[ __ ] i'm talking about at the swap meet
it was uh like three for five dollars
that type of cheap very scratchy fabric
it's the scratchiest [ __ ] fabric on
earth you're like why am i neck [ __ ]
itch all the time man you know like when
you know like when you would buy that
shirt and then you would wash it and
turn into a halter top
those are the aaa shirts yeah and so
nowadays with a lot of like clothing
companies and brands they're starting to
realize that their name is bigger than
the actual product that they actually
put out yeah and so you know i i just
bought a bunch of stuff on black friday
got it and it's a triple a shirt and you
know to be honest with you
lightweight kind of pissed me off yeah i
just even on sale i just paid like
[ __ ] 30 40 bucks for this shirt for a
shirt that i know that when you process
this and you make it it probably cost
you like 10 cents yeah and then i just
paid 40 for it it's like for what what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] about yeah and i
think like when it comes to people who
want to make clothing and and you know
all these like fashion brands that kind
of develop off of the name versus
actually caring about the product this
is what you get yeah when i was in japan
i remember uh i went to uh in tokyo the
supreme store
picked up the shirt and it didn't even
have the supreme tag on it
like if all of them did and i had there
was a mistake on one of them and i said
gildan yeah shirt was 120 bucks right a
gildan t-shirt right
a five cent t-shirt and they're charging
a hundred and twenty dollars that's what
hype does though you know what i mean i
mean you know kudos to like
the core founders of uh supreme and the
marketing that they did for it whatever
it was because i don't know the
intricate details behind it whatever
they did it worked i think so the
supreme story is that
they were originally a skate brand right
right and so they did something where
they actually got a cease and desist
and so people only know about the recent
onslaught of this where supreme did a
collab with um was it gucci or louis
louis they did it with everybody
everybody but
we started with like louie right they've
done a louis collab yeah yeah so they
started doing this collab where they
were doing it with um high-end brands
well they actually did that previously
before without that brand's consent and
i think it was louis vuitton
uh you guys could look it up um
they got sued yeah they did a cease and
desist because it actually started
becoming really popular so they were
putting that monogram yeah yeah it was
the only box the louis monogram and
everything with the supreme theme on
their skateboard and it blew them the
[ __ ] up and make them from like a nobody
escape that kind of people knew about
and it blew them the [ __ ] up they had a
cease and desist and they [ __ ] sued
them and then i think they won off of
like a parody clause or something like
that well from that point on it already
grew their [ __ ] name so they were the
first ones to kind of bring in the whole
you know streetwear and luxury and
mashed together lo and behold a few
years back they did a legit collab with
[ __ ] louie yeah right and so that was
the onslaught of the original part that
where they actually got a cease and
desist and got sued yeah and so that's
like how they kind of blew up i mean
yeah you can get notoriety from a pure
accident like that you know uh whatever
the case is yeah you need that luck and
timing to hit and um doesn't necessarily
represent like the quality of the [ __ ]
that they're making it just sometimes it
can be something simple as a celebrity
being caught wearing something right and
then overnight it just blows the [ __ ] up
because everybody now is look googling
that brand to be like how can i get that
hat or how can i get that tea remember
d9 yeah yeah with con the paparazzi who
was wearing it kanye's like yo that's a
dope hoodie where'd you get it sold out
their whole stock in one day yeah they
sold out their whole website in a single
[ __ ] day yeah that's what that's what
i'm saying it like even if that is a
manufactured incident like it they
planned that
even still it's just one of those things
that creates the hype machine and once
the hype's behind it it's pretty much
like open season man and
you know as a
as a creator it does
kind of kill me inside when i see like
our peers i guess
the quality that they're doing look
there's nothing wrong with using blanks
absolutely nothing yeah
startup brands need to do it we've done
it with our capsule collections but
here's the difference is like there now
we're at a place where there's so many
blanks available if you're of a certain
stature certain brand
that's at a level where it's like you
guys are doing relatively well and you
have good brand awareness there's no
excuse absolutely no excuse to cheap out
and get like bottom of the barrel blanks
yeah you can get some nice premium
blanks and have your brand be
represented in a certain light right
like yeah we make quality [ __ ] whether
we cut and sew it from the ground up or
we use blanks whatever the case is it's
going to be quality and it's going to be
consistent across the board you know
but
like you said there are these
established brands
who for one reason or another
are
using not such great quality [ __ ] and i
know that some of the high-end brands
like high-end streetwear brands again
i'm not going to name anybody either
that do that as well and people gladly
pay [ __ ] 150 200 for a t-shirt
and they have no clue that they're
buying a blank
and it's like how do you well so
that's justified because the name value
right because this is the brand and
we're at this level now so whatever we
slap our [ __ ] [ __ ] on now it's
instantly worth this much yeah
and it's like
okay well if you know that and you're
okay with spending 150 200 then i can't
say anything that's your money you spend
how you want to spend it but also
i feel like people should be
a little bit more educated on what it is
that they're buying
oh 100 and
i think one of the things that we worked
on um
on uh the back to basics a release that
we recently did is a lot of people don't
know but you will know when you receive
the product is everything was made
domestic yeah and i don't know if you
guys understand what that entails it's
when you hear somebody makes all their
clothing domestic number one
the biggest reason why you don't hear
that a lot and it's made in bangladesh
indonesia um china yeah
it's because it's cheaper yeah
it's it's cheaper but here's the thing
so here's the trade-off right
is just because it's made overseas
doesn't mean it's inferior exactly right
we've had overseas production but that's
what legit factories you know um when
you're doing overseas production
one it's hard as [ __ ] to find a good
factory people when they're starting out
have to spend thousands of dollars and
countless hours traveling around
visiting factories to see okay do they
do a good job even when you think you
found one that does they could fool you
they show you [ __ ] like oh yeah we made
this and then you get your production
and you're like what the [ __ ] is this
the alibaba sweater yeah it's the bait
and switch right
um so
i think there's a kind of a negative
connotation with like overseas
production is it being like inferior bad
or cheap no it's not that because even
though it might be cheaper per piece
there's a minimum there's a minimum that
you have to meet in order to work with
some of these bigger factories let's say
for a certain style and a certain color
the minimum is 1200 pieces when you're
starting out can you do that
let's say let's say you got two two
colors for one design a black color and
a white color that's 2 400 pieces you
have to do just on that good luck yeah
exactly unless you got like luck some
major guap or some [ __ ] you know
investment like it's going to be hard to
do that so that's one hurdle that you
have to kind of get past when you're
doing overseas production finding um a
good factory to do it with and then the
second one is meeting the minimum
requirements right but
the focus here with our back to back or
back to basics collection and doing it
domestically was you know a couple of
things right like
we suffered during the pandemic but then
so did all these other small businesses
and once i found out that like people i
knew uh who were involved in the
business here locally
we're doing this type of stuff i'm like
you know it would be great for us to
like invest in this and you know have it
be a win-win for the both of us right
they get paid to do a job we get uh our
products made um that was one of the
things and two is quicker turnaround
times generally because with overseas
stuff you gotta kind of slot out three
to four months at the lease with all
these port issues going on three to four
months is if you're lucky you know what
i mean and so that that wasn't a factor
when i made the decision but thank
[ __ ] god i did make that decision
because we might not even have the stuff
still yeah right now you know
um and two and then thirdly it's uh you
know domestic production too same
problem potential problem is overseas
finding a good factory is not easy yeah
finding a good production house is not
easy a lot of these factories here in la
i don't mean to [ __ ] on them but i'm
sorry they're [ __ ] garbage their
sewing sucks the fabric selections that
they have suck every their their
customer service like nothing is good
about it and it's no mystery why so many
of them have been closing shop over the
years
and then you know like they have the
audacity to complain about oh you know
the overseas stuff is killing our
business well then you do better yeah if
you do better people will gladly pay
higher dollar for it yes cost of labor
and everything is more expensive here
raw materials more expensive here but if
you do good [ __ ] work bro
when we were trying to do a domestic
program before the pandemic
it took me
about four months of searching just to
[ __ ] find the factory willing to take
on the project yeah first of all it's
like we're paying you to do a [ __ ]
job what you do but yet you're saying
you don't want to do it because it's a
little too complicated for your taste
yeah
i was
my jaw just dropped i'm like i can't
believe what i'm [ __ ] hearing yeah
the industry
the production industry is [ __ ]
struggling in la but yet you're passing
on business
they're like oh yeah we want simple
stuff like just a t-shirt or like you
know just the crew neck a sweater so we
have blanks it's like no we don't want
blanks like we this is what we want and
they're like no it's there's too much
details going on and it's gonna take too
much work and i'm like wow wow so that i
i was like [ __ ] flabbergasted about
that first of all and then when we did
find um a a production house to work
with my brain farts this podcast is
brought to you by skillshare listen let
me cut to the chase i know you're like
me you have hobbies you have goals and a
bunch of things you want to learn and
try but you don't know where to get the
right information and yeah you can
search online for hours and for the
right class but i'm telling you you
don't need to deal with any of that
[ __ ] just get
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community that offers
membership with real meaning with so
much to explore real projects to create
and the support of fellow creatives
because skillshare is about real growth
so for me the course i'm checking out
right now is youtube success script
shoot and edit by marcus brownlee one of
my favorite creators of all time i've
been doing youtube but you guys already
know i've said it multiple times there's
always room to grow and learn and why
not learn from mkbhd himself so remember
explore your creativity at
skillshare.com brain and get a one month
free trial premium membership that's one
month of a premium membership at
skillshare.com
brain
yeah no so i was saying like yeah when
we did find um finally a production
house to take on the project you know
this guy
over promised all this [ __ ] in terms of
timeline like you know whatever
and long story short um
he took i think like four times longer
than what he originally quoted us yeah
and just kept [ __ ] giving me the run
around and i was pissed because like we
already put in a 50 deposit we can't get
that money back
and
this [ __ ] is just like stringing
me along he'll tell me oh yeah you know
we'll have it ready by next week next
week comes can't get in contact with him
can't get an answer can't get an update
i gotta [ __ ] go over there he might
not even be there sometimes i was
so pissed but i couldn't do anything
because it's we're too deep in the game
at that point you know that was our
first major setback and
um for those of you guys who are
familiar with our collection the pieces
that i'm talking about in particular
here are the track pants so those track
pants were supposed to come out about
like
five or six months before than when it
did you know and so we lost a lot of
[ __ ] time [ __ ] up our whole
schedule with our shoots with our
releases everything
and it was because of this one [ __ ]
guy who just could not
keep his word or give me something
straight you know what i mean
that happened and then right following
that the pandemic happened not too long
after yeah you know so it was it was a
double whammy for sure but like
yeah you know this like we had a point
where it was
we had to look at the situation and be
like okay do we want to
just cut our losses here you know take
the l or
do everything we can and possibly turn
it around you know
and for me
it felt like
tucking my tail between my legs and
[ __ ] running away if we gave up at
that point yeah and it wasn't out of
stubbornness it wasn't out of ego or
anything it's just like what we have
been able to build up to that point and
i feel like hopefully anyway
what customers have come to recognize
what they can expect from our brand like
the attention and detail that i mean our
returning customer base is pretty
amazing yeah it is it is i think like
that is one of the things that i know
that
i didn't have with like the other stuff
that i had much yeah was
i think people
liked like for example when we did
something like go for broke right or any
product that we have
the biggest shift that i made was
let's not just sell something based on
the name let's sell it like
if i wasn't here would you still wear it
you know which for merchandise is never
that way yeah right merchandise is like
you wear it specifically because you
[ __ ] with me heavy right and when you
wear that shirt it's in support of me
yeah which is [ __ ] amazing um i
wanted to do the next step it's like
okay if i tell you that i'm an investor
in this clothing brand
what i wear
do i enjoy it yeah is it something that
i'm proud of
when everybody when anybody who has
owned a secret society piece right from
our very first collection and in between
we had a we put out stuff that that
helped keep us afloat yeah but our solid
collections from the the the onslaught
of the 213 collection that we first put
out yeah then to the the the 1.5 yeah
and not the back to basics yeah
not a single person
took got our stuff and hated it no it's
impossible yeah you can't you can't look
at it and be like oh you know this is
not good quality or there's no good
value there and that was the thing man
that was kind of like the whole ethos
behind secret society right is that we
wanted to represent the masses and have
this sense of community through clothing
and
have it be accessible like because
exclusivity exists in fashion as well
and people get priced out or you know
they do limited quantities and like they
can't get it even if they want it right
i didn't want either of those things i
wanted clothes to be like accessible and
have anybody
reasonably be able to afford it you know
yeah i i understand some pieces like if
you're working like a minimum wage job
you might have to save a little bit but
it's within reach it's not impossible
you know what i mean like a [ __ ] 300
t-shirt like that's for a minimum wage
person but that's the thing too like i
think like everybody who's a returning
customer they understand this is this is
high fashion like streetwear basics yeah
which you hear people who do high
fashion basics but they don't put the
money and the quality behind oh
absolutely that's what you're paying for
absolutely and because i've worked in
the fashion industry and our partner
remy who's the head designer for those
of you guys don't know
he worked in the industry we know
what these [ __ ] guys are doing some
of these [ __ ] highway uh high-end
streetwear brands are getting made from
our production house yeah and i know
their quality is inferior to ours now
again i'm not going to [ __ ] [ __ ] on
them by saying what their names are
because i'm not i'm not trying to hurt
anybody's business but like we are very
aware very well aware of what our
competitors and our peers are making and
so like we stack up our [ __ ] to them and
be like okay are we
at the very least meeting what they're
doing and giving it to people at a much
more affordable price
or ideally we're doing better than what
they're doing and still giving it at a
better price
which is our primary goal every time we
do and that's what secret society is
it's like yeah you're getting
i'm treating you guys how i want to
treat myself exactly
exactly that's basically what it is and
i think that's the the part that makes
me feel really happy when we have such a
crazy returning fan base yeah so you
guys know what's up you know for a fact
that when you went to the other fashion
basics place and they charged you an arm
and a [ __ ] leg and you didn't get
somewhere near the [ __ ] that we got yeah
it's like yeah our stuff
looks unique
it feels even better and it's
at the same price or even less than what
they charge exactly man that's i always
say you know value and design
fit and feel you know what i mean across
the board and and like
i think that's something that we've done
um a pretty solid job of executing on
obviously my goal is to do bigger and
better things with that in mind you know
but at the end of the day i know for a
fact like people can't knock our product
so i've always been proud in that sense
but like i said it does hurt me a little
and kill me a little when i see these
other brands who might have a bigger
name value for whatever reason and i
know exactly what the [ __ ] type of
fabric they're using and how they're
getting it made and it's inferior yet
people gobble that [ __ ] up you know what
i mean like it's the gospel so
that's something that
you know is is always going to exist for
any brand obviously whether you're in
clothing or any other industry right
it's just branding and marketing i think
this dope [ __ ] is like i remember when
um like for example i just texted him
today so we have in the back to basics
we have our our ss logo our secret
society logo and this is a heavyweight
oversized tee like true oversized so if
you if you like wearing your clothes
loose and you typically wear a large
it's going to be oversized in a large
right
a lot of people when they name oversized
right so i have a i know a couple of
people who have clothing brands and i've
ordered their oversized stuff in support
of friendship and i got their stuff
they
got a blank oversized and when you get
blank oversized you get what you pay for
so for example is oversized on the width
but the length isn't [ __ ] right so
when you wash it it's a [ __ ] halter
top so it's super wide and boxy but it
doesn't drape correctly yeah and these
are the small details that i think that
secret society does well compared to
everybody else it's all in the [ __ ]
details this is one of my favorite
oversized tees and i'm not just saying
that if you look at the color on this if
you guys are watching this on video i
watched this [ __ ] twice already it's
black as [ __ ] yeah yeah how often do you
get to wash a black shirt and it still
stays as black and again um i think
that's
kind of a testament to our experience in
the industry i feel like you know a lot
of times when people want to start a
clothing line they have no experience
like with with the technicalities and
kind of like the actual stuff education
behind
so much yeah it's just people like
printing and they're like oh that's how
you start a clothing line and they don't
know anything about fit fabric shrinkage
garment dying you know like they don't
know any of that so they just think oh
this looks good let me do it so again
going back to the whole thing even with
the blanks
you can use blanks and you can have it
be quality right if that's what your
circumstances require for whatever
reason it doesn't matter if you're big
or small
but you got to know what to look for in
blanks and you got to understand [ __ ]
specs right which is measurements for
these things grading which makes sure
the grading is done properly from small
to exit whatever your size chart is that
the measurements make sense
and like kind of the fit that you're
looking for but a lot of people have no
clue about this type of [ __ ] and they
just think oh if i put
print a cool graphic you know there you
go that's my brand like now i have a
clothing line but
no there's tagging bagging yeah even
that stuff like this
exactly everything man dude i've told
this story
it took me months just to find our
[ __ ] bag manufacturer because
i was i wanted a specific die-cut handle
on our bag so that when people get it in
the mail they feel like they went
shopping because you hold it like a
shopping bag yeah
nobody here domestically i've contacted
countless factories when i was searching
none of them could do it i'm like why
why is it so hard to do a die cut handle
on a [ __ ] poly bag i don't understand
either they didn't want to do it because
it's an extra step or they didn't have
the technical know-how to do it yeah
luckily um somebody i know uh referred
me and that's somebody i know [ __ ]
family
referred me to somebody they had worked
with overseas and they were able to do
it so like
most people would just be like nah i'm
gonna [ __ ] buy a blank box or [ __ ]
buy a blank polybag and you know that's
the packaging but like i can have it too
continue yeah continue go ahead yeah i i
care about [ __ ] like that where you know
i want you guys to really [ __ ] feel
like it's a customer experience when you
get it there you go there's the bag
right there you know so that's what i
mean like this die-cut handle
[Music]
like when you get this in the mail
i mean obviously this kind of beat up
but
you know when you get this in the mail i
wanted to feel like you went shopping
wherever your mail is whether it's in
front of your door at a different you
know mailbox at a different location
like when you grab it just even for that
instant to feel like you went shopping
and
that's why that's why like these things
matter to me and
luckily luckily like we've had our
customers recognize things like that and
and i've had people hit me up like yo i
noticed you know you guys did this and
that i'm like oh [ __ ] dude thank you so
much for wrecking that i don't even
expect that type of recognition but
thank you for recognizing the [ __ ]
details i mean the best kind of thing
too is when i'm just wearing it and
somebody goes oh where'd you get that
yeah
that's [ __ ] tight exactly i don't
think i've ever because even with gopher
broke right like i enjoyed it i love the
messaging and the meeting was so
dope right right but i'll be honest with
you i don't think anybody ever came up
to me looked at my stuff yeah that
gopher broken was like where'd you get
that dude um a couple months back uh i
was going on my way to visit my my
parents and i had to pick something up
stop by a plaza i see this kid head to
toe [ __ ] rocking secret society right
and i [ __ ] pulled up next to him and
i'm like yo bro i see you rocking the
secret society right and then he's like
laughing he's like yeah man yeah no
that's okay though you know like yeah
for me i just thought it was so because
i've seen other people wearing that [ __ ]
but like from head to toe it was my
first time you know and in another city
[ __ ] like 25 miles away from l.a just
to see a kid rocking that [ __ ] i was
like yo that's [ __ ] dope man doesn't
know who we are yeah
they [ __ ] saw it like yo this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] dope yeah and and like dude when
we're sending orders out to [ __ ]
australia to uk to canada like asia dude
you know this there are people who've
paid [ __ ] 60 in shipping just for a
hat yeah and i'm like dude the fact that
they want to [ __ ] buy a 30-something
dollar hat and pay double in shipping
for that it's amazing it's incredible
it's [ __ ] incredible so like they
they too enjoy the fact that when they
where people ask where they get their
[ __ ] like yeah you like it's like this
brand called exactly so there's like
this there's a
it's hard right yeah the hardest part is
that
per everybody's advice it's like dog
just put it on whatever it's cheaper you
make more money yeah but am i happy with
putting that out exactly there's a
there's a there's this thing about like
i know it's so stupid for a lot of
people right but there's this idea about
legacy legacy [ __ ] matters absolutely
right it it would suck for me to
verbally say out loud i can't believe
these clothing companies give me guild
and t-shirts then i give out a gildan
t-shirt too what kind of [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] person would i be exactly i
can't sit there and then
say that stuff upset at the fact that i
paid forty dollars for a shirt yeah that
i knew cost five cents and it feels like
[ __ ] sandpaper which i texted him
today i was like bro this shirt feels
like sandpaper what the [ __ ] yeah and
even then i knew the quality of
our heavyweight
uh oversized tees but
i really knew when i got my black friday
clothes yeah i was like well not just
the teas though man those are hoodies or
sweats and like look i know um for those
of you guys who have purchased this
stuff oh that's the odin coat by the way
i talked about this coat yeah like the
odin coat too this was from our first
collection um when we did this piece so
for those of you guys who are listening
you can go to
secretsociety.comrtsociety.com to see
what this looks like it's called the
odin coat so this has three quarter
sleeves it got some
shoulder straps here so you could hang
it off your back i mean yeah it looks
cool aesthetically but it's also
functional too you know and that's
always the thing we can't just do things
for the sake of it looking cool like
there has to be function and
practicality behind the two this is a
bonded jersey fabric which is i
guarantee you you see no [ __ ] startup
companies using fabric like this yeah
you know why because this [ __ ] not
even street high-end streetwear high-end
brands use this type of fabric to make
their coats and blazers and [ __ ] like
that we did our pants our coats and our
hoodies on our first collection with
this type of [ __ ] and i'm so mad the the
hoodie i [ __ ] loved right yeah but i
got that hoodie when i was 300 pounds
and so i had to give it away because i
couldn't wear it yeah it was that we
didn't you know obviously it's a
one-time release thing it's not like we
have a back stock for ourselves right
right so i'm like [ __ ] i miss that
hoodie so much but i i couldn't i can't
wear it because it's not made to fit
oversized yeah so that's doofy on me you
know yeah um yeah but yeah when we were
doing this coat like that god i missed
that hoodie that hoodie was [ __ ] sick
this style
uh
the design style was uh pretty much
inspired by kimono you know that was
kind of like the shape and look we were
going for and we have ss embroidery on
the back here but yeah i mean look dude
just the attention to detail is like
i don't mean to throw it like that i'm
sorry
coat disrespectful that's the thing too
right so like when you get like the odin
coat right
i think the the feeling that i get that
makes me really happy is that i get to
look at our previous lines and say hey
remember that [ __ ] line was dope yeah
i don't think a lot of people say that i
mean yeah
we could probably make more money if we
go ahead and do the the blank route
right yeah
but
this the thing is like oh what's for the
next season the next season is what can
we do to make more money yeah which is a
very smart business model but we're
trying to find that that medium and
between balance or we could put
something on say yo we need to make a
big paycheck yeah at the same time i
don't want people to walk away and feel
like they got gypped exactly i don't
like that because i don't want to feel
that not to mention what you said we
have our own standards you know and and
i'm a [ __ ] man of integrity man i'm
not i'm not gonna give people [ __ ] that
i wouldn't [ __ ] pay money for and
wear myself you know what i mean and
this podcast is brought to you by better
help if you haven't focused on your
mental health this year my friends what
are you waiting for listen i know you
because you are me and we need to talk
about the importance of mental health so
stop pushing your thoughts and emotions
aside and get the help you need better
help will assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room and you can
message your counselor at any time while
setting a weekly video or phone sessions
listen it's super convenient and more
importantly it allows you to be in your
own safe and comfortable environment if
you're not used to traditional therapy
listen i've used better help and it was
honestly an amazing experience and i
still use and talk to my counselor till
this day so give it a try you have
nothing to lose special offer for genius
brain listeners get 10 off your first
month at
betterhelp.com genius so visit
betterhelp.comgenius
get that 10 off and work on that mental
health my friend i told you this in the
text and we're talking earlier hype and
quality can exist together it doesn't
have to be one or the other but these
days it seems like it is one or the
other and usually it's the hype that
wins out because the marketing dollars
are there or celebrity endorsement like
whatever the case is the brand got seen
and and there's a much broader awareness
for it yet their quality is just not how
did how did like you and remy come up
with the or decide to go with what type
of fabric for the show so basically it's
different yeah yeah so basically when we
when we're choosing fabrics um you have
to basically get swatches right you get
swatches of fabric and it's you see the
hand feel of it you see like the weight
of it and then based on that you decide
like what type of stuff you want to make
how you want to make it and you got to
understand certain fabrics like let's
say you have a you want the fit to kind
of like more drape over your body right
certain fabric is not going to be good
for that you know certain weight is not
going to be good for that um
or you want something that
i don't know just feels a little bit
more thicker then you got to get a
heavier fabric to use for that right so
those are all things like we have
basically kind of a list of things that
we want to achieve with a certain body
and style and design and then from there
that informs us on okay what type of
fabric should we be looking for and
yeah we look at all of those feel it
look at it consider it reconsider it
it's not like a okay this is good boom
done
we sit on it like okay
going over this again how do you like
the feel of this how do you like the
feel of this you know
do you like the weight of this better or
do you like the weight of this better
then from that point on once we decide
something we'll go into sample
sampling doesn't mean though that we're
going to move forward now with that
fabric if the sample doesn't turn out
what we were hoping for
then we have to go back to the drawing
board okay this fabric's not working for
this type of body this type of design
you know
let's let's uh revisit which samples i
mean which uh fabrics we're gonna pick
so like oh dude the process is just like
there's so many [ __ ] things involved
right and
you know you're essentially an
entrepreneur when you're doing something
like this and when you're an
entrepreneur with limited resources you
gotta wear many different [ __ ] hats
um i showed dave a picture of my place
earlier and when we closed down the bus
or when we closed down the office at the
beginning of the pandemic i moved
everything into my place
when i tell you there's not an inch of
like for me to [ __ ] move around up
there
it's it's crazy it's [ __ ] but
we did what we needed to do in order to
survive you know because we didn't know
what the future was going to hold at
that point it was brand new territory to
everybody like a year and a half almost
two years and not putting out a single
[ __ ] product yeah it's yeah
and and we can do yeah and that's why
when we came back with this back to
basics collection started letting people
know about it look we didn't [ __ ] do
like
advertising for it we just tapped into
our community of people who already uh
know our brand who've purchased
something or engaged with us on some
level just let our community know hey
we're making a comeback this is what's
been going on up until this point like i
was communicating with them throughout
the process of like what's going on why
we haven't been releasing new stuff
what's taking so long
and explaining to them okay
we've
kind of like doubled down now and going
all in on making a comeback yeah and the
[ __ ] response we got was incredible
you know it was [ __ ] incredible like
i was blown away because
i didn't have much expectation i'm like
dude we haven't done new stuff in so
long it's literally going to be like
we're starting over again yeah and we're
finding an audience and finding a
customer base there's there's like these
a certain level of like pride that goes
into you know things that you create you
know like i think like doing clothing
too it's it's such an art form right
when you wear clothes it it can
literally change your mood yeah how you
look how you feel it's something that's
very important to a lot of people yeah
um and i'm trying to be a part of
something that moves past the idea of oh
you're wearing that specific design like
from this specific person yeah versus
does it look good right and i've had a
lot of issues with this because i've
seen a lot of [ __ ] that came out that's
just [ __ ] trash from a lot of high
name brands simply because it's just
dope to say that you had something from
there yeah and
it's these statement pieces that aren't
even really statement pieces they're
[ __ ] like like i think people when they
buy it they know it you know when you
wear a kanye west shirt right
and it's just a white tee and he's
selling it for 200
the only way i know it's the kanye west
shirt is if you tell me it's a kanye
west shirt
that's it yeah that's the only way yeah
that's the only way i would have known
you got it from like the easy line but
it's the flex there's no flex behind it
right yeah but it's like okay and then
you know yeezy will say or yay will say
hey
this is all kind so the fabric blah blah
blah cool well guess what we do it too
but we do it at a quarter of the price
and better and better and better i mean
hands down i don't give a [ __ ] look i i
will uh gladly put up our [ __ ] against
the best of them out there it's just we
don't have the name value and the brand
value as some of these bigger brands and
companies and so
you know it's always uh you alluded to
it earlier about like finding that
balance right between being a
businessman and a creative and just
trying to find that perfect medium
between the two
and at the end of the day like the
guiding principle still is like man i'm
not gonna put [ __ ] out there that i
wouldn't pay and wear myself you know
and i want people to feel the same way
like dude when somebody purchases
every [ __ ] order that we get i
appreciate that [ __ ] you know what i
mean because they're supporting
something
not only are they feeling like a dream
and a passion project but it's something
that we work tirelessly for like the
amount of sacrifices that i've had to
make you know what i mean to to even get
because we could have folded a long time
ago you know what i mean but
for me like
yeah i i was making good [ __ ] money
not doing this [ __ ] but something else
but i left that because making good
money is not
what matters to me it's not on the top
of my priority list it's about doing
something that's meaningful and
fulfilling to me it's that legacy yeah
it is it is it's hard man like it's hard
to explain sometimes when um
like we talked about it too like the
disheartening thing it's like you see
these companies who
pretend to do what we do
and people eat it up and we know it's
like you know but but to be fair about
that
maybe they're not necessarily
knowingly misguiding their customers
they just don't know better yeah they
think their [ __ ] is good but that's
because they don't have experience in
the industry they've never made clothes
before on a very technical level working
at like major companies this is maybe
their first foray into like making
clothes yeah and they think it's the
[ __ ] but actually it's just [ __ ] yeah
you know what i mean i mean it's it's
it's it's hard because here's uh here's
a you know here's a brand that i [ __ ]
love yeah right
human made okay but [ __ ] that price is
pricey dude i think their clothes is
dope like i love their [ __ ] i have a i
got a human-made cap i got a shirt from
them and let me tell you something i got
that [ __ ] on on a [ __ ] flash sale and
they rarely do that [ __ ]
very rarely yeah that [ __ ] was still
expensive i just wanted it because
number one uh
their fit tends to be a lot smaller
because it's geared towards a japanese
crowd so they always suggest to go up in
a size or two if you're american yeah
but
even like the quality of the [ __ ] is
dope and i think that's what i
appreciate yeah it's just do i
it's hard for me to spend
400 on a coat right you know what i'm
saying it's like this is hard off this
like you know they had this one uh
human-made it was like it was just like
a khaki uh it was a khaki just like an
outdoor coat right it was like 480 yeah
but i liked the way it looked i was like
this [ __ ] looks [ __ ] dope and you can
tell like the attention to detail that
they have on there on their pieces
but 500 bucks
you know what i'm saying
because of who it's attached to yeah
it's a hard buy for me no for sure like
unless somebody wants to gift it
[Laughter]
my amazon wishlist amazon wishlist
shout outs to human made you know and i
also know because pharrell's attached to
it and i think um
like bbc stuff billionaire boys club i
think their [ __ ] is dope i've been
rocking their [ __ ] for years yeah you
know so there's definitely brands who
still do it really well you know we just
want to be a part of that conversation
as well no for sure and again going like
the code that you mentioned going back
to our code i know for a fact like some
of the high air high-end wear brands um
that were using this exact fabric like i
was saying earlier who do sell their
coats for like 500 bucks 600 bucks you
know and people might look at our price
but i think we came
our original price point for this uh
when we released it i believe was like
175 people might look at that and be
like oh that's too expensive but it's
because they have no context you know
they don't have perspective i just told
you about a code that costs 500 yeah and
it's a fraction of it yeah and that's
kind of part of the marketing the
educational part of it right teaching
consumers why this is value why we're
giving you bang for your buck um and the
goal is obviously like from a business
standpoint that we can grow so we can do
bigger and better projects and you know
we can make even doper [ __ ] with with
even better quality and like make our
lines and collections a lot more robust
because dude there's so many things i
still wanted i want to do even though
our [ __ ] is uh dedicated i mean marketed
as unisex and we do have a pretty good
chunk of female customers i do want to
make like a dedicated uh women's line i
also want to do kids line of stuff
and like that's not all because like oh
i want to make more money it's just
something that intrigues me no i can't
wait till we start doing denim
the denim is something that i wanted to
do at the very beginning but it's just
too expensive we cannot hurry
so we can make you guys better stuff man
i cannot wait yeah denim is also one of
those things that's very hard to tackle
absolutely hard it's so [ __ ] hard
it's so you have no idea like
i've probably in the last
two years bought so many different
denim jackets and i've hated
it's been hard yeah like the way that it
fits like
just the type of denim that they're
using yeah just everything about it and
i'm like ah i don't like these man like
i just there's something missing about
it so i'm like
that's the one thing too like every
secret society piece i got one of these
jokes that one of my friends he goes i
always see you wear that washed secret
society [ __ ] shirt in every video i
was like you know why because it's my
most comfortable shirt
i'm not trying to like promote it i just
it's the most comfortable shirt that i
own yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
so i asked this fool to give me two of
each to each color
and i wore them down to the [ __ ]
thread yeah just holes in them
i had to finally let go of three of them
because i wore them too much well that's
when you transitioned to pjs you have
speeches now they're pj's
they got obliterated in the washroom
because i wore them so much during
pandemic because they were my most
comfortable favorite shirt yeah you know
and now this one is like my favorite one
yeah soon this will have holes in it
yeah
i wear my [ __ ] out dude so that's you
know that's something that i can promise
you know
anybody listening who's interested in
secret society [ __ ] or already a
customer of secret society is that like
look whether we're cutting and sewing or
using blanks it's we're always going to
have the same attention to detail you
know we're always going to look at it
from a standpoint of like okay does this
fit with what we're trying to do what
we're trying to create and is there
value here for the gus for the customer
if they spend their money and purchase
this product
and if that if those check boxes aren't
checked then it's a hard pass for me
move on to something else then you know
and i think for as long as we continue
to do this for as long as i do this
all those guiding principles are going
to exist the moment i start compromising
on those things is when i just say you
know what
i'm done with it then you know like if i
can't realistically execute on things
the way that i want to that i feel like
makes it worth it for people then
there's no point doing it anymore
because that's what is
despite all the headaches and the stress
and you know
it still makes me feel fulfilled and
happy that i'm prof it's the classic
case of oh you think you could do it
better then you do it yeah okay i'll
show you and we are doing it better it's
just people don't recognize that because
our brand awareness is not on the level
of some of these other brands yeah so
the hope and goal is that secret society
becomes synonymous with value in every
sense of the word and that's what i hope
people
listening in and have not ever bought
anything from us
understand and if you do decide to take
that uh plunge to purchase something
from us hopefully you'll see what it is
that we're talking about that's kind of
like that space when i look at it it
reminds me a little bit of like what uh
zara did
for
like uh
like contemporary basics right mm-hmm
because before that it was forever 21
and h m mm-hmm and
their stuff falls apart yeah easy yeah
so if you need something really quick
for a weekend yeah and you know you're
gonna go out of town it's like cool i'll
get this 10 shirt this [ __ ] 12 jeans
or whatever it's like a temporary thing
it's a temporary thing because you're
not gonna get rid of it within two weeks
yeah right and then zara stepped in and
it's like we can do
a portion of what they do but we'll give
you something a little better yeah the
price might be a little bit higher but
it's going to be worth it yeah and it's
still relatively affordable yeah it is
it is and so like i kind of pictured
secret society fulfilling that role for
you know that streetwear contemporary
fashion basics yeah and that's where i
see us at yeah and
it's been happening that way where
people the return our returning customer
base understands that they go no matter
what wherever wherever else we've went
or gone yeah the
fashion basics that they have in terms
of like streetwear you're not going to
get it anywhere else at the price that
we're giving it yeah like i'm telling
you you guys go get
a heavyweight oversized tee and then buy
one of ours and do the comparison yeah
after you wash it after you look touch
and feel it you will understand
why it's better and how it fits on you
how it fits is the most important part
yeah and um i think there are definitely
again going back to the whole education
thing there are a you know group of
customers who might not be too in tune
with fashion and this whole oversized
thing and they might get something and
think oh this thing is too big but we
have the details on the product
description it's oversized yeah we say
it's a classic fit or oversized fit and
we even say on these new tees from the
back to basic selection if you want a
more like a classic fit than size down
so for example if you wear a medium get
a size small you know because if that's
the way you like it that's the way you
like it i'm not knocking it but if you
get it and you say hey this is way too
big
well we got all the information for we
say it's oversized we say the size down
i don't know what else i can tell you
about that you know what i mean yeah but
you know that again i'm not blaming
people for not being aware of kind of
like the fashion trends and you know the
whole thing but
just
do a little bit of uh reading it's right
there yeah yeah yeah yeah get as easy as
possible for you guys to understand what
it is that you're getting you know yeah
what do you what do we have planned next
um so
we got those uh
i'm not gonna say ah [ __ ] it i'll say it
the the bag you know that you yeah so we
got that coming in the pipeline so this
is not this sling bag we already got
this this is the flint slingback but
it's my everyday sling yeah we got um oh
dude people have been [ __ ] loving
this [ __ ] because [ __ ] it's the perfect
size it's water resistant it doesn't do
more than you need it to do you know it
does exactly what you needed to do and
um i believe the price for this is 35
dollars so crazy yeah i mean and it
comes with the wrist strap you know what
i mean like which one of these sling
bags do you see that's what i'm saying
these little attention to detail and it
serves a function yes it looks cooler
with this on here but if you want to
take off these shoulder straps and just
carry it on your wrist like this
it serves a functional and practical
purpose too
if you're an asian person out there and
you're getting asian attacked put some
[ __ ] coins in that [ __ ] and start
swinging that thing baby like a mace
two centers i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i'm saying no you can fit it in
here easily hey shout out to the dude in
junior high no today monday
if he had that sling back he wouldn't
have to
so our next um thing that's coming in
the pipeline is um yeah this duffel
backpack oh yeah
we have the sample yeah that basically
now let's save that you know i want them
to see it you know in its entirety
that's the prototype that dave has here
but
yeah it's gonna kind of be like your
everyday essentials back whether it's
for the gym for a weekend getaway
gateway
hey it could be for a gateway too
they'll do a gateway too you know but uh
weekend getaway um and
the dope [ __ ] about this is it's a
duffel bag that doubles up as a backpack
so it's called the duffel backpack it's
the [ __ ] dude yeah i'm so hyped you
didn't bring anyone but it's all good
yeah it has every compartment you could
possibly need and the form factor i feel
like is perfect because it's not too big
and it's not too small yeah yeah there's
like there's a lot of these pieces that
we have that i'm so happy about i know
barbell brigade has their um one of the
pieces that i really love from barbell
brigade is their um they have their uh
it's like this
it's called their mark ii shorts okay
but it's their one of the most
comfortable shorts i've ever worn yeah
and it's um it could be used as a swim
trunk or a gym short yeah and [ __ ]
dope and i think they got put on like i
forgot what publication it was but it
was something big but it was like top 10
best uh workout shorts of the year and
they were put on one of it nice that's
like like number two or something like
yeah it was [ __ ] nuts yeah and it's
just it's a small brand yeah and they
were in the likes of nike adidas and
everything else and their brand was
there and those are those pieces that
really matter i mean they're in the
fitness space and we're in something
else yeah but we're trying to carve out
that space in this area and i think like
once secret society becomes that it's
going to be a really happy day for me
all of us man for all of us you know
when people see this and they're wearing
it every day it's it's one of those
goals of mine yeah i know i have these
weird tick goals you're like aren't you
a comedian aren't you but there's also
other stuff that i want to do along the
way yeah everything that i've done so
far that i believe anyways
has had to deal with a certain level of
quality yeah you know what i mean
june b matcha right we now have
um
we have a we have currently opened what
four stores and we have a potential four
or five opening up right now yeah and
it's because of the attention to detail
behind that right that was
even with that brand too it has to deal
with accessibility yeah it's high-end
matcha done in a casual way to show
people like listen you don't have to you
don't need a [ __ ] geisha to come out
and play a little loot you don't have to
be one of these guys
to drink high quality matcha and that's
the thing that happened with matcha too
people were being served the shittiest
form of matcha and they were paying
paying a premium price
you know so they were paying a premium
price
mike
you know they're paying a premium
they couldn't stop you know they're
getting dipped and i couldn't say
anything about it but
they're paying a premium for culinary
grade matcha and so with the brand that
we worked on was listen
this is your everyday drink right
but it doesn't mean that you have to let
go of quality this is the highest
quality grade market that you can get at
this price and the way that we do is
that we work with the farms so that's
why we can serve it at the price that we
have you may get a matcha drink
somewhere else and it might be even a
little more expensive or the same price
but it's not the same match that we have
right i know this for a fact i've served
it to so many japanese people the same
thing that they get they go
i miss this matchup because i don't live
in japan anymore
and that right that's their greatest
compliment greatest [ __ ] compliment
yeah you could ever get hammered it's
essentially the same thing that we do
with this brand which is why i invested
into it yes what we get to bring to
people yeah for the price that we have
yeah you know and it it really does make
things accessible and look man when that
resonates with people just like the
compliment about you know it reminds me
of japan uh matcha
when people
mess first so any of you guys who are
listening or watching uh when when
people message me and tell me how much
they like the [ __ ] and then like
resonates with them bro it's like it
[ __ ] makes my day makes my week you
know because like the blood sweat and
tears are getting recognized on some
level and i'm not again i'm not i don't
have this expectation for people to
recognize every little thing that goes
into this no that's beyond their their
knowledge their scope of knowledge for
everyday things right because it can get
highly technical but if you just like it
and you felt it was money well spent and
you tell me like you you take a moment
to just like let me know i [ __ ] with it
dude that's like such a [ __ ] great
feeling because it's like okay you know
what we're doing something right yeah
and look man they're from the very first
collection like we [ __ ] did it on a
level that i would argue
i mean it's an arbitrary number i can't
confirm this but i would say like 99 of
startups don't do to this day even like
our lookbook video people still [ __ ]
compliment us on that yeah shout out to
brian dos reese you know he del rios
yeah that's our homie brian he's in
boston [ __ ] talented uh
you know videographer yeah visionary all
of that and um he really [ __ ]
slaved a way to like make this to make
the vision come true in this you know so
shout out to him but yeah we still get
compliments to this day about that
because again you know why no matter
what even though we're not recognized on
a worldwide level you cannot knock on
the [ __ ] quality from the visuals to
the clothing everything and that was
always the thing man it's like we got to
make sure that's on luck you know
marketing yeah sure i wish i had more
money for [ __ ] marketing even like
the photos that we had were [ __ ]
amazing shout out to [ __ ] justin
vasseur dude yeah exactly justin at the
time now justin it works for barbell
brigade yeah but justin at the time was
living in vegas dave hit him up i
remember this specifically we were in
your car we had a group call with him
you're like i know this kid he's
talented photographer he probably would
be down
we talked with him and i gave him the
little pitch of what the the brand was
such an amazing job yeah and he came
through from [ __ ] vegas didn't sleep
and yo i like justin knows this too i
i've always appreciated what he did on
that thing too because
it was a [ __ ] grueling process like
five days each day i think i was running
on like two hours of sleep you know 20
hour days yeah and then you know from
that point on his work ethic was great
we i hooked him up with barbell right
now he works for barbell right right
so [ __ ] yeah
no no no no justin justin is somebody
that like we've worked with he he
actually shot one of our product shots
for um
[ __ ] what was it i think it was the box
tease yeah i think he did the the k-town
collection and the box tease like he did
the product shoot for us so it was great
to work with him again on it um but yeah
shout out to justin very talented guy
too but yeah dude from the very
beginning i feel like we did
infinitely more in terms of like our
visuals to the the quality of our
products and our offering than startup
brands tend to do
and it made me so happy that people
recognize that and still recognize that
and i think it's a testament when you do
got
[ __ ] man we're not nowhere near a
household name but yet again people from
[ __ ] different countries are willing
to pay 50 60 70 bucks in shipping for
one t-shirt one hat
and i'm like yo that's incredible hey
real talk i wouldn't even do that
no matter
how much i like a brand i wouldn't
[ __ ] pay 70 in shipping to get a
[ __ ] hat you know what i mean
appreciate it but i appreciate that [ __ ]
to to the fullest because even i
wouldn't do it i'm like damn
you think that shit's dope enough for
you to do it yo that's [ __ ] love
right there you know so
man
i hope bro i hope we can keep the
[ __ ] wheels turning with this [ __ ]
and it's always a struggle because we
have a [ __ ] skeleton crew with
limited resources and we're still always
trying to
hold that high level across the board
but it's not always easy yeah you always
need this more money and more time right
yeah and it's something that we always
have less of and not enough of and we're
still trying to
maintain
our guiding principles yeah and
i think hopefully anyway people have
recognized that to this point and
hopefully we we just yeah continue to do
bigger and better things moving forward
man i mean it was kind of crazy too
because
i think like one of the things that kind
of helped me reiterate
and
made me really happy about what we were
doing is it's actually sad though it's
you know the passing of virgil abloh
yeah right right like the stamp that he
made in fashion is in
is nuts yeah it's timeless it's gonna be
timeless he's in the history books you
know and look
didn't no had no idea he was suffering
from cancer i know me too i think it
caught it's one of those things where
even like chadwick boseman right a lot
of people had no [ __ ] clue he was
about battling cancer just like doing
what they do being great at it
suffering quietly and privately
but still excelling at what they do the
craziest thing too like i remember just
he came out with the uh air max uh there
was the mentes and the original
off-whites right the air max 97
and that's the first thing i copped um
didn't leave it in the box because i
love the shoes i wear them all the time
but that was one of those things where i
was like oh this is hype but the shit's
[ __ ] dope and i bought it and i still
love those shoes till this day i wanted
to get air max mentis but i was too late
on it and then they were worth like
buying it was like two thousand dollars
i'm not paying two thousand dollars for
shoes right i think it's worth like 5000
or something now but
um
him passing away reminded me like
you could do both
yeah could have hype and you could have
quality right his [ __ ] was [ __ ] dope
man yeah like
like he had he had the uh what's it
called the the essentials collection too
which is really [ __ ] dope too like
all the all the stuff that he's touching
he's done he left a stamp he left the
legacy behind right
and obviously there's a lot of celebrity
endorsements behind it but that didn't
change the fact that his his designs
were [ __ ] built yeah you know yeah
everybody who has a virgil apple piece
knows that it's still yeah and and look
man that's like um again just paying
attention to the details because those
details mattered you know and without
that
honestly the most likely end result is
just making a subpar product yeah you
know because it's the small things that
make a difference look when we were
doing like our hoodies and making our
pants
so it's called bar tacking where you
reinforce certain parts of the clothing
where
pressure tends to be because you your
hands are slipping in and out of it you
want this part bar tacked so that it's
reinforced and prevents ripping tearing
right
even our production guy was like dude
what like why you gotta do that i'm like
because it matters man and i will just
[ __ ] do it dude i will pay the extra
money to do it you know even though that
it eats into our margins it doesn't
matter because for me i'm like that
should be a standard you know
again the value part and so
yeah there are times when a lot of these
brands
are getting away with just doing the
bare minimum you know and maximizing
their profits from a business standpoint
i can't knock that you know i cannot
knock that because it is a business at
the end of the day but
like we keep saying you can do both you
know you can do both and still be
successful and
we'll see we'll see what the future
holds right at this point we made a
strong comeback with back to basics our
black friday sale was amazing and so
november was a great month it was a
great way to come back but
how we do in december in 2022 we'll see
man but the focus is there now
i'm fully committed again you guys have
no idea what i sacrificed for this [ __ ]
it's at the sacrifice of my [ __ ]
comfort from every level financially
mentally physically everything like when
i'm talking about giving blood sweat and
tears i mean it literally man and
figuratively okay i
every once in a while right it's healthy
it's healthy to release can't keep it
all pumped up you know
yeah but um
yeah
it's hard to put into words
you know just to go back to that whole
thing of should you start a clothing
line yeah you can
just know that
just know what it entails it's a lot
yeah there's a lot of work and you know
blood sweat and tears and passion behind
it yeah if you want to just do merch
anybody can do merch that's perfectly
fine yeah i think one of the things two
people have always asked how come
where's your merch at
i listen if i do merch it's gonna it has
to be dope right because you're gonna
have to wanna wear it just like the way
i wanna wear my [ __ ]
you know and it's so weird it's like
well you don't have to make merch like a
clothing line it's for money i know but
you know when have i ever done just
anything solely for money i've been on
the space now for what 11 12 years and
it's never been that way there's so many
things i could have done for money that
would have made me fallen out of my mind
right but then every day it would eat at
me you know like i got to this point
doing some [ __ ] that i didn't respect
right and it would just kill me yeah and
you know what some people can be okay
with that i'm not one of those people
unfortunately because i could have made
my life a lot easier i wish i would both
know yeah let me tell you something
[Music]
you could have done something very
simple
it just pisses me off in this day
all he had to do was just [ __ ] put a
ring on it
but you know again it's just one of
those things where like man i'm a man of
principles i'm a man of integrity and as
cliche as that might sound or as stupid
as that might sound it's the truth man
and
my decisions and the way i've lived my
life are proof of that there's no
inconsistency in any of the decisions i
made where i'm like okay you know what
ah [ __ ] it you know like i'm just gonna
let go of this [ __ ] and just make more
money instead
like look man everybody needs money but
you might think i could have done pranks
and just punched old people on the
street exactly
and i think i could have done that yeah
i remember look that's a conversation i
remember you and i having like years
back when you know you were growing and
i think you would like just crossed over
the million mark with your subscribers
and like your whole content creation
process and i remember you telling me at
that point like quality still matters to
you yeah like it's not about just
pumping out whatever is going to get the
most views and be the easiest to do
because you could have done it very
easily i could have dressed up as kim
jong-un and scared people
that would have been easy yeah
yeah i would have made [ __ ] millions
of views and at that time the way it was
monetized right i would have made
millions right i don't ever look back at
that and say oh i wish i would have done
it yeah because the life that i have now
is also just as great
also too like
you know i talk about not giving a [ __ ]
what people think but there are certain
people in my circle who are family to me
that yeah their opinions do matter
because i allow it to matter to me
because of who these people are and
places in my life i guarantee you
there's no way i would have done stuff
that was soul stripping that's demeaning
and i made millions and those friends of
mine would have still been my friends
because
they can't be around somebody they don't
respect and i don't want to be around
myself if i don't respect myself either
absolutely i wouldn't even hold it
against them it's like you know what
they stopped being around me because
they couldn't
they can't look at me and i get it and i
don't want to live like that that's just
too hard yeah and people say well you're
rich and bald i keep telling these
people you all think [ __ ] money is
everything money is not [ __ ]
everything you and i we're all gonna
[ __ ] die you cannot take that [ __ ]
with you and look
that's coming from two people who grew
up poor
you literally cannot take any of that
[ __ ] with you you cannot take money with
you you cannot take any of that stuff
the only thing that you can leave behind
is what you create yeah absolutely and
look man i'm not saying that money
doesn't make things easier that money
doesn't give you freedom of course it
does provides all those things but when
you're so money-centric and money-driven
and think money is the end-all be-all
and you you [ __ ] you know disregard
every other thing in life
you're gonna find out the hard way
you're gonna be lonely with a lot of
money nobody to share it with and be
like what the [ __ ] is my life yeah and
i'm not just saying this as an
assumption right you have to understand
too i'm in an industry
and
in the company of people who have this
type of money and i got no real ones
around i see them and it's and their
life actually scares me yeah it scares
me man like even these young people too
that are young youtubers they watch me
growing up right and they have hella
money yeah because of the content that
they make and i'll ask them a simple
question like i asked this young girl
who was killing it in like the the the
youtube food world right yeah and i'll
go who are your friends she goes i don't
have friends and i'm like
i know this sounds harsh but i
i killed myself it's like i traded
everything in the world to to work every
day yeah and not have a single [ __ ]
bond yeah at like the age of like 25 26
you don't have a single [ __ ] friends
one of the saddest things you can hear
to be honest you know what i'm saying
and then they're like i don't trust you
how do you don't trust people when you
don't know people you know absolutely
[ __ ] all else and then you see them
they're laughing they're doing all this
other stuff and you meet them in person
they're the most miserable people you've
ever met in your life they're like in
their 20s it's like yeah
i see that and that [ __ ] scares me and i
see it with older people too who have
traded everything for it yeah and i go
they go i can't trust anybody it's like
that's because of the life you chose
yeah that is your choice you made that
choice to prioritize money and use
people around you to get where you
needed to be so this is where you're at
exactly you reap what you sow right um
and i think a lot of times like people
just have these unrealistic expectations
of what life
is gonna be
once you know oh i make all this money
then life is going to be like this this
is my greatest example of somebody who i
admire right it doesn't mean i
necessarily like i you know worship this
guy or anything else like that but joe
rogan
he has created his own empire he has and
he supports his own friends mad props
and there's not a single company that
can control him right he's even built
his own company on it and it makes
millions he did it
his own way yeah and everybody else
followed suit you know what i'm saying
he's the one that popularized you know
podcasting for a lot of people and he
wasn't even the originator he wasn't
yeah that was adam corolla and really
the original podcast was probably
[ __ ] what's his face howard stern
yeah howard well even bill burr was
doing a podcast for joe rogan yeah
you know what i'm saying when i look at
somebody like joe rogan he didn't have
to cut corners in his own integrity yeah
you know you may not find him funny you
may find him to be
too [ __ ] whatever liberal or too
right-wing or whatever the [ __ ] it is
right the thing that i'm talking about
him is that he created his own empire
his own way and made his own money he
has both his integrity intact and also
the money that came along with it and
and you know dana white the president of
ufc always says this
joe rogan doesn't come here and
commentate because he needs the money
yeah it's because he loves it he
actually has fun doing it he does stand
up yeah not because he needs the money
right it's cause he loves it right he
signed a gajillion dollar deal with
spotify he is fine for the rest of his
life yeah he is okay he does things
because he loves it right yeah he
interviews people on his podcast because
he's curious about the stuff that they
want to talk about
that's what i appreciate about him the
most absolutely no i agree with you 100
man is that when you do things your own
way and still are able to have success
with it now let's provide context here
it's rare very rare right yeah this is
where i mean joe rogan is a joe rogan
right joe rogan is kind of like a joe
rogan but there are people who will
gladly sell their soul to have the
success joe rogan has as well yeah
there's more people like that i just
can't be one of them yeah that's all i'm
saying to do it so it's like yeah
i i know it's a slim chance
but i enjoy it yeah i enjoy watching
that happen because i don't know how
many times i've been to these stupid
little [ __ ]
hollywood soirees and [ __ ] like that and
everybody's just sucking each other's
dick off even though i know the type of
[ __ ] that they say about each other
behind each other's back exactly as soon
as their back's turned even in the same
room they're talking [ __ ] yes and then
they come around
it's like oh my god i fake ass [ __ ]
dude it happens all the [ __ ] time
yeah i see it every day like
some of these people come up to me right
and they do man i really appreciate your
work and i'll be like no you don't you
know the [ __ ] i am yeah you absolutely
know [ __ ] all else
i was like i know what you do know about
me though i was like you know i got a
big mouth
i was like you know that if i don't like
you yeah and you do something really
stupid i'm not gonna just not say it
because you're asian yeah i i will
[ __ ] rip you a new one because i am
in my own world right tomorrow all the
stuff disappears i'll figure something
else out yeah i'm absolutely okay
there's no you cannot control me
whatsoever yeah and i'm a depending on
the paycheck
so it's like a caveat there hey listen
you know when people listen to this
podcast you know my reputation i know my
reputation in the hollywood circle i'm
considered a liability like they look at
me like oh this kid doesn't give a [ __ ]
yeah i can throw an opportunity at him
like he knows it's like like i've heard
like peers in my circle it's like dude
you did that podcast that you didn't
like shang chi
who the f stole the [ __ ] what what does
that mean yeah what what the [ __ ] does
that mean they go oh what if like simon
wants to work with you
if he wants to work he won't he'll want
to work with me yeah if he doesn't
because i didn't like a movie that he
didn't create that he got paid for that
he's still famous for he could suck my
[ __ ] dick yeah that's all that it is
right nothing against the guy and i'm
just using him as an example because of
what people said to me yeah you know
this is nothing has nothing to do with
it but it's just like using him as an
example of why i can't say i like a
movie or not because of oh how it's
going to make me personally look
i'm not in your hollywood world you stay
in hollywood you do that type of stuff i
have a great life absolutely and so
yeah i'm not going out of my way but if
people go hey review shang chi because i
want to know what you thought about the
movie and then i go oh it was the best
movie ever because of feelings
that's inauthentic
i'll give it a fair try yeah and by the
way like i said before a million times
over everybody who was mad about that
review i watched it three times
and then i did a review on it yeah or
twice and then i watched it again yeah
and then the third time i watched it i
shut it off halfway so
i watched that movie more than you did
so i gave i actually gave my put my
money where my mouth is so you can't say
[ __ ] to me yeah so i gave it three tries
yeah so it is what it is yeah so i think
you know at the end of the day too it's
like i understand how these circles run
and i know what people have to do like
being in those like social circles where
they're just like oh man hey bro i love
your stuff uh i could literally tell
them it's like oh what do you like which
which video
it's like oh you know the one you did
like last week yeah
and the funny thing is like going into
one of these recent stuff that i went to
people know who i am
they know me very [ __ ] well they see
me in the audition rooms they saw [ __ ]
yeah and they he listened to the podcast
because guess what the same people that
came up to me they were like oh dude
like
i didn't like shanghi either
and they go oh i'm so glad that you said
that [ __ ] because we need honesty well
you say it
because they're scared exactly they
don't want to burn bridges so you want
me to burn alive you want me to take all
the criticisms because i get to
represent how you feel yeah and then but
then you'll shake hand and smooth with
everybody else and throw me down you
know throw me down a [ __ ] set of
stairs right just to make you look good
yeah cool i know where you're at no
integrity man that's what i'm saying no
integrity no backbone it's like if
you're not doing and saying stuff
because you think it might be an
unpopular opinion and it might burn some
bridges with potential people that you
can work with
look some people could look at that be
like oh you know that's stupid from a
business perspective right but
business isn't everything man money
isn't everything that's what you know
for me and this is i say it because i've
done it right yeah i was denied roles i
was denied auditions because of who i am
and i proved people wrong i didn't get
to do my own stand-up shows i got pushed
back and back and every time i was
trying to do stand-up i got a
five-minute spot 10-minute spot yeah
what did i do i blew up my name on
youtube and i was like [ __ ] it i'm gonna
do my own 30-minute show i'll go out to
these colleges i'll pull out a show and
people will come through i just did a
genius brain show 300 people showed up
let's [ __ ] go yeah i will create my
own [ __ ] path it may not be a big
deal to you because it's not 10 000
people yeah but those 300 people that
came to that show [ __ ] with me exactly
and that's what matters that's what
[ __ ] matters the same thing goes for
secret society that i talk about with
these customers who support us um
that's why [ __ ] i it touches me man
it really touches me my [ __ ] cold
black heart yeah
it warms it up but he won't cry this
wasn't crying as far as he cried in 20
years yeah i might be a serial killer
but
that's a different story you know um no
but that's that's what i'm saying is
because i know like the people who's
been [ __ ] with us since day one they
know man they know and they understand
and they've been riding with us till now
cause dude think about how many
different things are fighting for
people's attention in this day and age
not just clothing anything breathing
everything right and the fact that
the response we got with the back to
basics collection when it dropped means
they were waiting yeah they were waiting
for us to come out with new [ __ ] thank
you exactly thank you so [ __ ] much
man because
you didn't have to you could have just
[ __ ] spent your money and the time
was i promoted it zero that that's the
thing well let's be fair though in the
beginning you you helped the people with
this new line right which was like i
haven't talked about i mean we're in
transitions right now of you know
fulfillment and stuff yeah so i you know
i've been kind of hands off right now
yeah but it's kind of nice to know that
the brand is surviving not because of
who i am right it's because people
[ __ ] with it there's some there's
something that's irreplaceable about
that yeah like i it's hard to describe
and the back to basics marketing
campaign zero zero
zero dollars were spent on that it was
just to our community it was just to our
community our emails and that's it yes
yes man and look our even our instagram
account like we were talking about this
before of like how engagement has
dropped off significantly just across
the board for instagram now right like
we were so inactive on our instagram
account like when we were posting stuff
it was like abysmal so it's not even
because a bunch of people are seeing it
on instagram it's literally our [ __ ]
community of people who have been riding
with us and again for those of you guys
watching or listening i appreciate that
[ __ ] like it's seriously [ __ ] from
the bottom of my heart i appreciate that
and that's one of those things that keep
me going man because i'm like if i
didn't have that and yeah we got no
customers
then yeah you're like what the [ __ ] i'm
not [ __ ] just making clothes for
myself to wear yeah or for just us to
wear i can do that too you know for fun
this isn't for fun this is like a
[ __ ] passion
i'm not giving the advice to people
either to say like hey live with your
pride and be poor yeah saying that i'm
saying right absolutely yeah that's
stupid that's absolutely dumb yeah you
know but i'm saying that there's a way
in a path to to kind of meet in the
middle
you know and i think that middle spot is
a very good spot to be at right yeah is
to live and live in reality but also not
to you know shed everything about your
humanity just so just for a paycheck
yeah you know i don't under no i don't
know if people really get that time is
very finite here and what you say and do
really matters yeah you can only do it
to the best of your ability but if you
only chase the dollar and once again
this government people who grow up
really really poor
like i've seen it more often than not
right um
how
living a certain lifestyle leads to a
certain way here's the biggest example
if you guys read a will smith's [ __ ]
book
you'll see a representation this is will
smith the guy who's at the peak of
everything his influence his power
whatever that was
literally
[ __ ] so much anytime he came he threw
up
that's crazy i've never even heard of
that
i've never in my life this is at a young
time i would masturbate so much and i
felt fine my dick was raw
but i would not throw up
but you know will smith talks about his
ups and downs dealing with like the
industry you know all this other stuff
losing all his money blah blah blah the
hard work and look at somebody at like
that he's really showing you these life
lessons and these are people that you
admire
come on like
how many times can people who you look
up to tell you the same advice and for
you still not to get it and understand
exactly right how is it that there's
people who don't know anything about
twitter social media instagram facebook
um [ __ ] snapchat whatever
how are they so happy when you say that
you need to be happy because you have
these numerical values that that depict
what you're worth yeah but they don't
have that and they live completely happy
they don't have what you have yeah they
don't have the car the roof the fancy
[ __ ] whatever so how who are you to tell
these people that they're not happy
that's your definition of happiness your
misery is based on what the position
that you put yourself in right now right
not all the time but i'm saying for
people who live in a first world country
who have first world problems right i
can't tell my friends who i know
who aren't envious of me at all
that they're not happy because they
don't have what i was like well how can
you be happy like people you're not
recognized you know what i mean you
don't own this type of stuff and they go
they'll be like [ __ ] you
you know [ __ ] tell me if i'm happy or
not based on what like based on what and
at the same time too if you're somebody
who feels like that's your mode of
happiness
then go for it i'm just telling you from
my personal experience being in the
industry that you want to be in and the
position you want to be in i know nine
times out of ten that those people are
left with not very much yeah and because
it hasn't been dis proven to me a
majority of the time
um and you might throw examples of me at
people but i'll tell you those people
that i know i know the opposite story
because i know them personally you don't
know what goes on behind closed doors
right you know absolutely they do it for
the [ __ ] paycheck yeah i know they do
for the paycheck because i see how
miserable they are yeah and they always
asked i met up with somebody uh uh for
lunch at the beginning of pandemic and
they literally met me up to ask me they
go why are you always so happy
they're like
i don't get it like why are you always
so happy i'm
like i don't complain
you know what i mean i was like what are
you searching for and this person was
you know is an actress and i'm like
why are you an actress right
because the way you talk about art it's
very to me it's very vapid it's very um
you talk about art in the way that you
feel like you should talk about art not
because you actually care
like oh you know this artist this movie
blah blah blah the way that that
why are you talking about this while
we're having lunch yeah it's because you
want me to know how knowledgeable
knowledgeable you are about acting so
maybe the better question in that
instance isn't why i'm happy why are you
unhappy exactly
and this person started tearing up
they're like what is it that you have is
like i don't care about the stuff you
care about i was like i'm in this
industry i i do what i do but you know
what i care about my friendships the
[ __ ] lime and i'ma eat tomorrow
morning
with two poached eggs
and my mom's kimchi that she made me
yeah and then i
that's what i care about my value my my
sense of values are so different
compared to you
so because you value something that's so
[ __ ] fleeting booking this role
because of how it makes you look so you
don't want to look like a failure to
your parents you don't want to look like
a failure to your friend you don't want
to go i don't worry about any of that
[ __ ] i said i want to do youtube because
youtube makes me happy when youtube
stopped making me happy i started to do
film i did the sundance film cool i did
that i want to do food so i started
doing food i did stuff that i found the
balance between making money and then
also having integrity right and this is
what i do right you can never tell me
that i'm not successful based on what
your set of value of what success is
yeah you can't tell me oh david you
haven't booked a huge movie yet i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah you give a [ __ ] to tell
me that
you feel like you're feel sad for me
because they're like oh man you had such
hype with the [ __ ] film but you never
asked me if i wanted to act
exactly and and it just might be the
case that their definition of success
and happiness is not your definition of
success in i would have leveraged that
[ __ ] and i would have done all these
roles cool the problem is i found out
when i went into acting i hated all
these roles yeah and i didn't want to do
them yeah well the only thing you got to
say is cool but are you me yeah exactly
it's like you're not me yeah they're
like oh i would kill the bee on a
multi-cam multi-cam sitcom i don't want
to be on a multicam.com you never ask me
right so why are you telling me that
that would make me happy yeah stop
saying this [ __ ] this is this is a this
is an asinine conversation and so you
know after we had this conversation they
kind of understood it i'm not sure if
they did but it's like for somebody to
go i like i didn't think i was like this
extremely happy guy
but they're like oh you have all these
negative comments like there's like
reddit threads about how a piece of [ __ ]
you are i'm like why are you reading
them
i don't
i know people hate me you know why
because i'm opinionated i have a big
[ __ ] mouth right i understand what it
entails yeah it doesn't bring me down
who are these people what are they gonna
do to me yeah nothing yeah
absolutely [ __ ] else unless they're
china
[Laughter]
you know
but just to go back it's it's everything
that i do has to deal with that even as
an investor as i invest in the secret
society it's
i don't wear this because i'm trying to
sell it where cuz i genuinely like like
when i brought him all the [ __ ] from the
new collection a couple weeks ago when
we did the podcast with ed um like dave
was so giddy and excited
yeah he's like dude this [ __ ] is so nice
and it's so comfortable you know so yeah
like guys it's not just we're not just
making [ __ ] for the sake of making the
most money as we possibly can with no
integrity behind it no care or attention
and detail behind it if anything i would
argue that we're doing more of that
stuff
than focusing on making as much money um
but again it's a business so we do need
to make money and we do need to make
more of it in order to grow because now
we are at a bottleneck where like we
need to hit the next scaling process
it's very risky for us so like
now us moving into getting a fulfillment
service is kind of what's on the table
for the near future but
that it's not a lot of money but any uh
money going out is a risk for us because
that means less money we can use for
production but it's part of the process
of growing right it's like if i can't
focus on things because of all of these
other
menial tasks that need to be done that
are necessary to be yeah yeah yeah we
can't grow the brand plain and simple
yeah so that's where we're at but
oh man i i really hope dude i really
hope more and more people can recognize
what we're doing um not just through the
podcast but yeah just just word of mouth
too because that's like the best
another one of the best compliments you
can get is like just somebody oh
somebody else told me about your brand
you know and those moments that you've
had like hey yo what's that brand that
you're wearing yeah i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
let me tell you a little something about
it taste something like this
and before we sign off like i got to
tell you like i you know
this is stuff that i always tell edric
too because of what they pick out it's
it's like they could read my mind about
what i want before i even say it you
know
like i have the biggest issues with
[ __ ] hats
yeah so many [ __ ] hats that i buy are
[ __ ] and you'll see a lot of repeat hats
that i wear because i like their
specific fit yeah you know human made
was one of them when they wore their dad
cap i was like this fits right this is
this is this is it yeah and i bought
three other four other dad caps hated
them gave away to all friends i was like
you have this [ __ ] and like oh you want
to keep this [ __ ] the name it doesn't
fit right yeah like i just showed him a
hat today from a company that i enjoy
and you know
i got it i'm like [ __ ] this hat
yeah like what the [ __ ] this hat dude
the fit and feel of it was uh was
terrible questionable questionable this
hat right here this hunter green one
looks so [ __ ] good the way it fits
the way it's styled yes it's just it's
bright and this red one it ain't a mega
hat yeah like i i [ __ ] with this too
it's the foam trucker it's so light it's
so comfortable the shade hats are
[ __ ] firing yeah yeah so just you
know everything we do again it's hard
like um uh my boy kevin he's a
photographer who helped helped us with
this back to basics collection yeah
shout out to kevin i mean he he really
went the extra mile he was up with me
[ __ ] two wee hours of the morning you
know like working on [ __ ] going over
[ __ ] but his girl uh vanessa wants to
get into the clothing line you know or
wants to start her own clothing line so
she's been asking
and she got to see a little bit kind of
like what's going on and i'm like you
still want to do this really she's like
yeah
i guess it's like is this is it as
glamorous as you know you thought it was
i was like it's not right look at all
these headaches that i'm dealing with
right now i'm like it's inevitable for
you too so i'm like i jokingly say don't
do it but obviously i you know when i
get serious i don't hire the passion if
you love it yes exactly just know that
it comes with the territory and be ready
for it don't go into thinking it's gonna
be oh all glitz and glamour and i got my
own clothing line and so and once again
i think i really do enjoy the fact like
you know there's like little stuff and
that they know about clothing from being
a part of the industry that makes sense
i i
guarantee you
every [ __ ] person that you've bought
that said like oh we're doing we want to
just you know do our own clothing line
where it's dope high quality stuff if
you ask them what is high quality about
your stuff
zero blanks i'm talking about the
highest fashion bloggers [ __ ] daily
vloggers especially the girls who get
their clothes yeah
i've seen their [ __ ] it's funny funny
this is forever 21 [ __ ] don't you
[ __ ] dare sell your audience to stuff
like this is high quality [ __ ] i know
it's not dude i've seen your [ __ ] yeah
the fact that you could even go out
there and sell your stuff saying that oh
this is humane stuff like the quality
attention care you haven't seen [ __ ]
what you did was saw the design that a
designer made and you go i kind of like
it yeah but you don't know anything
about the product what's like okay
that's fine just don't lie to people you
know what i mean i think again it's just
ignorant you know what i mean they they
like they just throw it out yeah they
throw out these buzzwords thinking oh
yeah that's what you got to use it's
high quality [ __ ] it's the best but what
does it mean to them yeah you know what
i mean like there's no meaning behind it
because they don't know the technical
aspects of it so they say high quality
in what sense well i mean it costs 300
so of course it's high quality
no
price does not equate high quality like
i said
our production guy makes some of these
higher-end streetwear brands stuff and
like these reputable brands and i look
at it
i told you one of them he's like yo
check out this uh hoodie and i'm like yo
this is like some [ __ ] swap me [ __ ]
and he's like oh it's so-and-so's
i'm like get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
they're charging how much for this [ __ ]
i'm like this is [ __ ] garbage yeah
you know but here's the other thing it
worked the other way around for our [ __ ]
some of these guys from these companies
came by his place the production guy's
place and saw our [ __ ]
like yo who's is this
they start feeling it they're like yo
can i try this on you'll be like nah i
mean you could check it out but you know
this is like my other client [ __ ] like
this
my homie [ __ ] like you can't you can't
like try it on you could buy it when it
comes out they're like yo this [ __ ] is
dope yeah like what's what's their how
much does it cost to make okay never
mind
so they would inquire about us yo like
what's their website what's their
instagram what's the brand name
and like that made me feel good because
i know some of these guys are from
companies that are very well established
who are doing very well for themselves
yeah and these are the their head of
production or whatever and they're
looking at our [ __ ] and being like
double taking yeah yo who [ __ ] is this
this [ __ ] is dope hey we want to make
[ __ ] like that yeah you know
um so that tells you man if insiders
know what's up like we're doing it right
yeah we're doing it right and and that's
something that
succeed or fail i hope success but
succeed or fail i can live with myself
end of the day like we did it the right
way and we're giving customers what we
believe to truly be value in every sense
yeah well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast that
was always damn near two hours goddamn
that was a passionate talk
the podcast really goes past an hour but
it's just it's just [ __ ] important
man yeah and uh i hope you guys like the
secret society stuff man um
yeah i just i'm super happy about it i
it's just one of those things man like
it
i could die happy knowing that even if
the company doesn't does i mean it's
been four years i mean we've been going
yeah but i don't know we've been
surviving we've been surviving and
surviving we haven't been thriving yeah
we've been surviving yeah yeah i mean
you know due to everybody's support yeah
um but i'm gonna make sure that this
does well so hope you guys if you guys
[ __ ] with secret society um i guarantee
when you rock it you'll know what we're
talking about and when people look at
your [ __ ] and they ask where it's from
you'll know what it is man it's all word
of mouth too you know say it with pride
dude say like oh a secret society you
said right it's a it's a high-end
streetwear brand yeah you know and let
people know about it and let people
touch the fabric they'll see what's up
yeah and um matter of fact give your
give take the clothes off your backing
yeah so they know what's going on and
they suck their dick and then just
make a connection and a bond that way
you know what i'm saying yeah exactly do
what you got to do go the extra mile
come on guys we need the support all
right i know get on those knees and
[ __ ] do what you had eat some [ __ ]
let's go
but anyways guys uh you can catch edric
at ed2 remember uh secret society is
s-e-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y
be a part of the family wear some [ __ ]
that you know that the attention and
detail that goes into it and listen you
know let's get back to the basics man
fashion basics never [ __ ] die yeah
right these are statement pieces
whenever you walk around and what you
know what's up with it right this isn't
my merch it's a company that i invested
into because i believe in it so if you
guys [ __ ] with it
even if you don't [ __ ] with me you [ __ ]
with the clothes yeah just real quick on
the whole contemporary fashion basics
guys so like what we're talking about is
we take timeless pieces and give it an
update you know a contemporary update
with the fabric with the fit you know
the the the um
uh [ __ ] i just got a brain
but yeah we give it a contemporary
update and that's what we mean by
contemporary fashion basics so it's
meant to be something that you can wear
every single day no matter your gender
no matter what walk of life you're from
it's for everyone that's why we say
whoever you are you're one of us
well we'll catch you guys next time
every thursday sundays until january 1st
and we go once a week and after that my
friends uh i'll be with you every sunday
every sunday 12 p.m but until then
thursdays and sundays so see you all
next time s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y
junebe matcha j-unb
shop.com if you guys want to go ahead
and cop our match stuff or check out any
of our stores and get our dope ass
drinks and then also give me the number
to your mom so
we can hook up me too yeah bang bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang yeah did
you know your girlfriend looks like your
mom
see y'all next time peace